we had representatives of over 85
countries and international
organizations International and Syrian
civil society we can say we identify
common ground on at least two or three
issues one is that there is no military
solution to the war in Syria and that
the reason needs that everybody
recognized to relaunch the political
process the second element on which I
have not found any divergent view is the
key role of the United Nations in
leading this political process and this
is extremely important for us the
European Union because we've always
consistently identified in the United
Nations and Staffan de Mistura the only
legitimate leadership to ensure that the
political process represents all Syrians
in intra-syrian talks and happens along
the lines of the UN Security Council
resolutions already adopted and third
element is the need to support Syrians
inside Syria in the neighboring
countries with humanitarian aid
financial support but also to support
hosting communities in particular in the
neighboring countries and we want I
think collectively to pay tribute to the
work that Syrians are doing both inside
the country and outside of the country
to help their fellow citizens but also
to try and build the basis for
reconciliation and the rebuilding of the
social fabric of the country once the
war will be over I'm glad to announce
that in delegations here today have made
a collective pledge of 4.4 billion u.s.
dollar for this year alone 2018 moreover
for next year and beyond we have pledged
for 3.4 billion u.s. dollars
the European Union as a whole has
pledged almost six billion dollars until
2019 again we are leading by example by
being the largest donor now every single
cent we pledge today needs to be swiftly
translated into action